yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a little info video about future
channel updates um there was a time like
roughly 10 days ago when I was recording
the daily Blitz videos you have the
three Blitz videos a day that have done
for a really long time and we are now on
4400 for 4440 something yeah we had the
four four times four hundred recently it
was something that happened like 10 days
ago
I am yeah I didn't have an update for
the channel for the next day or the day
after that and I was really in a bit of
a rush I wanted to I wanted to record
the videos and I played to three games
and played there badly badly and then
lost all three and I yeah I kind of
recorded them I put them on the channel
for for upload and then the next day I
got some time and I played the next
games and and also when I started it
didn't really feel like playing I was
rather once rather to do something else
but somehow you you you have to do the
three videos a day because I'm you have
done so for such a long time and I felt
like why am i doing things that I don't
want to do and I don't feel like doing
at this particular moment and guys so
des so did two videos and again I lost
yeah just all the free games and I felt
okay this is probably not the right
attitude yet if you if you play and you
don't really really want to do it yeah
why do you do it why not do something
else it is not many time to do exactly
this format yeah do the three blitz
videos every single day so when I what I
did is I I completely I completely
canned those I don't know six or seven
videos I don't know what it was and I
decided to only record stuff that I
actually want to do yeah don't don't do
the Blitz videos for the sake of doing
them I think at the end it's just not
enjoyable yeah the videos that are
recorded there with those losses I mean
I don't really mind that that I lost the
games
I mean you rather want to show a games
value wind it's totally clear everybody
likes to show they're a good stuff and
the matter of the matter of fact is
those those videos because of my
attitude I didn't really want to play I
was really not in any good mood and this
is just not good content you should do
the things that you really like to do I
think it will make the better concert in
the long run so I decided to simply get
do daily recordings in a way I want to
have a daily channel update but I was
thinking I just do the things that I
feel like doing it when we have a day
where I feel like playing a couple of
blitz games and those days exist yeah I
had a really good session some days ago
and I'm really I recall it like 10 or 15
of those games and it was good I
actually was winning most of them and
had a really good run and I think this
is something that is kind of this is
kind of going in their hand if you are
in a good mood you play better if you
play better and your mood gets better
but if you start out being in a foul
mood this is this is not a good idea so
I was thinking I just do the things that
I feel like doing at a given day at the
given time when I'm recording which
means that the channel will be a little
bit less steady in terms of the same
three which games every single day there
will be games with three blitz the days
were three blitz games with there would
also be days with record games I have
recorded a ton of record games because
this is what I felt like doing yeah
let's do record game with a bit of
infrared it's a bit more relaxed you can
tell a little bit more
the positions and the next couple of
days will be a lots of rapid games on
the channel this is also I have to say
due to me being away a lot in the next
couple of weeks for for chess and for
small vacation so I don't actually have
that much time and I need to record
things in advance so there will be a bit
of rapid but I also think of doing some
other content yeah the odds video on
middle game on endgame I mean simply
it's not predictable it's just like I
what I will do now is I simply would
have basically on every single day I
have a small I have a time slot in my
calendar yeah do some YouTube and this
might be some little it might also be
something else and something a position
that I saw that I feel interested in or
I love a game whatever yeah it will be
less predictable and I think it will be
better in the long run for the channel
if I do the things that I genuinely
enjoy doing so um I hope those of you
who really like the three blitz games a
day are not matter there will be tons of
blitz are still on the channel it will
just be a little bit less regular also
take note that there'll at the weekly
live shows when also will be playing a
little commentary yeah I hope you
enjoyed watching this video and you kind
of understand what I'm what I remember
I'm talking about and I think it will be
better in the long run for the sake of
the channel thanks for watching